bitcoin's a decentralized digital
currency and there's lots of people over
the last two or three years they've been
talking about it as an inflation hedge
and so the big question is bitcoin an
inflation hedge well before we answer
that question the first thing we have to
understand is how investors actually
react to inflation markets they're
forward-looking people don't wait around
for inflation to actually occur before
they move their capital if i'm an
investor in the market and i think that
inflation is coming i'm going to go
ahead and move my money to be prepared
for that high inflation environment and
that's exactly what we saw happen in
2020 plenty of investors were worried
about high inflation and they went ahead
and they started to move capital into an
asset like bitcoin that led to an
absolute explosion in the price of the
digital currency and so today michael
saylor the ceo of microstrategy he had a
great tweet where he pointed out exactly
what's happened since then he said
bitcoin is the best hedge against
inflation since microstrategy announced
its first bitcoin purchase in august
11th of 2020 bitcoin has appreciated 149
percent outperforming silver which is
down 17 percent gold which is down 9
the nasdaq which is up 5 s p up 18 cpi
at 11.2 m2 at 19. u.s homes at 28
and ppi at 33
there's plenty of folks who are saying
wait a second inflation's at 8.3 percent
why is bitcoin falling but it's because
investors who predicted that inflation
was coming they already moved their
capital they've been prepared for this
situation and if they were one of those
people who foresaw this problem and
moved capital before inflation hit
they've actually been a huge beneficiary
buying bitcoin in preparation for
inflation as an inflation hedge was one
of the best decisions you could have
made back in 2020. that doesn't help
people who are in the market today but
of course markets are forward-looking
going and waiting until high inflation
is here usually isn't a good strategy if
you then want to buy the inflation hedge
asset understanding markets
understanding assets it's all part of
the game and bitcoin continues to prove
that it is the best inflation hedge
asset that exists